the phenomenon known as the Renaissance
is one of the standard stops on any tour
through the history of Western culture
it encompasses a roughly 300 year period
in Europe we're architects poets and
philosophers reconnected with the style
and ambitions of ancient Greek and Roman
civilization the reasons for studying
the Renaissance nowadays are often left
a bit unclear to the high-minded and
respectful
the rationale may seem utterly obvious
or to the more impatient or
technologically focused the exercise can
equally well appear a complete waste of
time
we believe that the main reason to study
history is to rescue certain good
provocative and inspiring ideas that
have been lost in the past in order to
put them to use in relation to the
dilemmas and problems of our own times
our tour of the renaissance while
seemingly about some old long dead guys
will hence really be about us florence
italy 1469 a 20 year old nobleman from
one of the grandest families of florence
lorenzo de medici takes over the family
business the Medici bank that's been
going since 1397 and is the most
respected financial institution in
Europe with flourishing branches in
Florence Venice Rome and Geneva
Lorenzo like his uncles and his father
before him has a great gift for business
during his lifetime the bank will open
new outposts in Basel Bruges Avenue and
Pisa and lend significant sums of money
to Royal cords aristocrats and
entrepreneurs Lorenzo and his family are
typical of the Florentine upper classes
of his age in honoring the business of
making money without any of the
traditional suspicion of trade found in
most Christian societies but not only
are the Medicis interested in making
money they are also extremely ambitious
about how to spend money they believe
that the express purpose of what we
would now call philanthropy is to
promote beauty truth and wisdom in the
world
Lorenzo de Medicis grandfather had
started the collection of books that
became known as the Medici library and
Lorenzo now expanded it decisively with
his
searchers scouring europe's monasteries
courts and libraries for lost or
overlooked texts from antiquity Lorenzo
was a patron of many philosophers
including motsi Leo fechino Paulo Tiano
and Giovanni Pico della Mirandola under
his guidance these philosophers
undertook pioneering researches into
Greek philosophy they absorbed the ideas
of Epicurus sino and Aristotle and try
to harmonize plato's theories with
Christianity Lorenzo is perhaps best
known as a patron of art his court
artists included Pharaoh Keough Leonardo
Botticelli Joel and IO and Michelangelo
the patronage was extremely intimate and
involved Michelangelo lived with Lorenzo
and his family for five years dining at
his table and participating in
discussions led by marci Leo Fujino
although the Medici were quite rich by
modern standards their fortune was a
relatively moderate one across four
crucial decades from the 1430 to the
1470s it's estimated that the Medici
family spent the equivalent of around
half a billion u.s. dollars on
intellectual patronage architecture and
artworks which is a huge sum by
comparison with average incomes but it's
not very substantial by comparison with
the wealth of the richest people today
the Medici family resources would be
roughly those of Rosetta Calf errata
whose wealth from a fisheries business
in Peru is around 1.5 billion u.s.
dollars she's at present the thousand
200th richest person in the world
Lorenzo would seem economically
unimpressive next to Giorgio Armani 8.5
billion and a nonentity next to Bill
Gates 79 billion money was important to
what Lorenzo and his family achieved no
doubt so in that respect the world is
amazingly well placed to continue in his
footsteps there's no shortage of money
to do the sorts of things he did but
what's holding us back today is a
shortage of vision for the price of this
yacht
Lorenzo fueled the Renaissance for 30
years a secret to the Medicis impact was
that they didn't see themselves as
they're simply to hand over the cash to
allow artists architects and scholars to
do whatever they wanted the Medicis had
a vision a mission for the Arts and for
philosophy and were extremely direct and
didactic in putting it forward usefully
so guided by his philosopher friend
Fujino Lorenzo thought of art as a kind
education under his patronage artists
were there for us to illustrate key
philosophical truths about say the
importance of kindness and compassion
they promoted serenity and glorified the
best qualities of the state and of good
leadership the Renaissance would never
be remembered if its leading members had
simply made piles of cash no one cares
about that for any length of time the
real source of its glory was the
imagination and intelligence with which
its great bankers and financiers set
about spending their money Monastery of
folder' Germany January 14 17 an Italian
scholar and humanist Biagio Brett
Shalini is on a tour of Germany in
Switzerland looking for lost Greek and
Roman manuscripts he is spending a few
weeks in a Benedictine monastery hunting
around the dusty shells of its great
library when in a forgotten nook he
makes one of the great discoveries of
the whole Renaissance he comes across
what still remains the only surviving
manuscript of Lucretius de rerum Natura
on the nature of things which gives us
the most complete account we possess of
the philosophy and worldview of the
Greek philosopher Epicurus broccolini
and his circle are astonished
Epicurus has hugely valuable ideas about
the human passions happiness religion
communal life and science this is only
the highlight of a career spent rescuing
lost manuscripts in time Brad Shalini is
to go on to discover key texts by cicero
quintillion and Vitruvius when he
couldn't by text he wasn't averse to a
little skullduggery to get what he
wanted he famously bribed a monk to
abstract a copy of Livy the Roman
historian from the library Herzfeld Abbe
in Germany Brescia Leaney was hugely
interested in classical texts but he was
not a scholar as we would understand the
term that is someone who wants to
investigate the past for its own sake
and respects the inherent nobility of
old books the Renaissance attitude to
history and philosophy was very
different its intellectual leaders took
a relentlessly practical view of things
they wanted first and foremost to run
their societies successfully to make
their people wise and to build
magnificent cities the epicurean
philosophy broccolini dug up with his
emphasis on friendship simplicity and
the acceptance of limitations wasn't
exciting to him because it was old but
because its wisdom was still needed
he wasn't looking for age
idea so he could fill in missing details
about how the past used to be perhaps in
order to gain a professorship in a
university broccolini was urgently
searching for help in creating better
ways of thinking for the present central
Florence 1484 michelotto de batalla Mayo
one of Cosimo de Medicis favorite
architects completes the family home the
palazzo medici just near the city's new
cathedral michelotto has studied Roman
antiquities closely and the building's
tripartite elevation beautifully
expresses the characteristic Renaissance
spirit of rationality order and harmony
this is a golden age of construction in
Florence Leon Battista Alberti has done
the facade of the Church of Santa Maria
Novella
Brunelleschi has put up the speed a
little in eternity and the city's new
cathedral dome and many less well-known
names are completing squares fountains
and thoroughfares the same is true for
the other great Renaissance cities of
Siena Venice Abbey no band over in Rome
city fathers across the Italian
peninsula have fallen in love with a
remarkable new idea that their cities
should be the focus of an unparalleled
attention to beauty it's slightly
embarrassing to contrast these efforts
with our own mess a sentimental view
says that the Renaissance city fathers
made nice places because they were lucky
they didn't need to plan for cars they
didn't have zoning laws and they happen
to have access to good quality building
materials like lovely stone you can get
from quarries outside Florence however
successful urbanism is never an accident
for the Renaissance it was a
philosophical mission the Renaissance
built such great cities because of an
idea that we are to a large extent
shaped by the character of the buildings
around us making sure that the public
realm conveys dignity and calm is more
than a luxury it can help to ensure the
sanity vigor and happiness of a whole
population what's more the Urbanists and
architects believed in rules they didn't
think it was chance that a city looked
good they wrote volumes codifying what
works and what must be avoided in their
efforts to systematize and in their
careful thinking about what makes a good
street corner pavement or bench they put
our own efforts at urbanism to shame
they believed in ideal dimensions for
squares that a square should be small
enough that a mother can call from an
upper window to her child
playing at the other side they thought
that all good squares should have large
elaborate fountains in the middle but
that the surrounding buildings should
mostly be fairly plain they knew that
buildings should be around five storeys
in height and there should be graceful
covered arcades so that citizens could
amble in all kinds of weather
Renaissance leaders like the Medici were
marked by the views of the ancient Roman
historian Sallust who'd been deeply
hostile to a situation that had
developed in the decadent periods of
Rome where there had been in his words
public check against us prevent him or
pawlenty a public squalor and private
opulence Sallust believed and the
renaissance leaders hugely embraced his
idea that in a healthy society the
public sphere itself should be opulent
that is beautiful refined and appealing
that way the richer people in society
will never be tempted to withdraw and
concentrate exclusively on their own
private estates and comforts and all
citizens will be uplifted by a pleasing
vision of communal life it's a tribute
to these efforts that there are still
very few cities on earth nicer than
those created over a few hundred years
on the Italian peninsula but it's also
testimony to our desperate lack of
ambition and vision that we can count on
one hand the number of cities
constructed since the Renaissance that
are prettier than say Florence or Venice
ideally we wouldn't have to be so
impressed by Renaissance cities we'd be
inspired to arrival and equal their
achievements in the architectural idiom
of our own times ferrari church venice
1488 a 58 year old Venetian painter
Giovanni Bellini completes a triptych
featuring in the central panel baby
Jesus and his mother Christian artists
have been painting this scene for many
centuries but things have only become
this powerful and convincing in the last
hundred or so years here the two Mary
and her little boy have looked stiff
often gaunt and wooden but with Bellini
Jesus is just like a real little boy a
kind we might see looking at seagulls on
the Lido down to his stocky legs
slightly swollen tummy and searching
eyes Mary feels equally alive vibrant
and deeply attractive and interesting we
can imagine her melancholy thoughts and
Intuit her kind sympathetic and
dignified nature if there was some child
care available it might be lovely to
invite her out to the gelée
Grum just a few steps away from the
fiery church it's often been remarked
how odd and wondrous it is that so many
geniuses of art came to the fore in such
a short period in one place Renaissance
Italy gave world civilization Donatello
Frangelica with cello Masaccio Filippo
Lippi Leonardo Michelangelo fail Titian
and so on how did it happen how do you
get so much talent in one go it's
arguable at every age has roughly
similar amounts of latent talent among
its artists what makes certain ages
extraordinary one thinks of the Golden
Age of Athens Holland 19th century
France or 1960s America is that they
know what to do with the talent they
give artists a mission they have a clear
sense of what art is for and they
therefore reward
and invest in artists properly or
distinguishes the Renaissance is not
therefore a freakish preponderance of
artistic skill it's an intensely clear
vision of what art should be for the
Renaissance could be described as a
heroic age of advertising yet the focus
was not on selling consumer goods it was
on selling beauty truth and wisdom the
energy we still feel behind their art
arose from a coherent ideological
programme the Renaissance wanted to put
painting in the service of ideas and to
make these ideas palpable effective and
life-changing one thing the Renaissance
was constantly advertising his
philosophy philosophers were in the
minds of many then as now rather
abstract and remote figures so the
Renaissance got one of its most talented
artists Raphael to lend them a bit of
life on the walls of the Vatican to show
us Aristotle and Plato and others as
belonging to a group of glamorous
fascinating individuals for his part
Titian was employed to convey a central
philosophical message about the brevity
of life in his three ages of man
existence is depicted as desperately
fleeting the child is soon an adult in
the adult soon ages and in retrospect it
all seems to have occurred incredibly
fast which makes it essential that we
use our time properly that we forgive
one another for our frailties and focus
on our potential while there is still
time but Titian and his patrons knew
that most people don't care to think
about how brief life is that's where art
comes in and has the huge advantage over
philosophy Titian starts with things
that everyone
the Renaissance already liked sexy
couples and cute baby angels the picture
is designed to take you without you even
noticing it's happening into an interest
in philosophy so that you naturally
start to engage with matters of life and
death the move is a bit like that made
by the best adverts of today that hope
to get you subliminally interested in
buying a chocolate bar or an SUV while
charming you with a beautiful couple or
a sublime landscape only in the
Renaissance the philosophical end goal
of art was worth the effort the
Renaissance concept of art as
advertising for the great truths was
underpinned by an ideology worked out by
the philosopher ma Sileo Fujino the
figure who taught Lorenzo de Medici and
spoke to Michelangelo at dinner every
day for many years
Pacino argued that we are all creatures
who love and love is attracted first to
beauty so whatever we wish people to
love we must first make beautiful and
beauty is first encountered as sexiness
so the path to the highest possible
human ideals tends to go down a complex
route first
to sex then to beauty and then to love
with such a theory to hand and its
impact on the art of the Renaissance
cannot be overestimated Pacino was able
to use what we might term sexiness lust
glamour and celebrity to serve the most
noble and high-minded intellectual
ambitions rather than being relegated as
they often are in our own times to
selling handbags or mobile phones never
before or since have so many big ideas
been so beautifully and often sexually
treated by great artists Fujino and
Lorenzo de Medici were fascinated by the
idea of getting Botticelli to engage our
sexuality in order to excite us about
ideas that they thought were most useful
to humanity that's why there are an
awful lot of very cute people in
Botticelli's work the hugely alluring
figures in his Primavera are for example
thoughtful kind and serious and
sometimes rather sad they're filled with
tenderness towards human sorrows and
failings and a keen to remind us of the
need to appreciate the cycle of life
they're also highly seductive you don't
have to believe in the virtues to want
to be like them
but because you instinctively want to be
like them you will therefore aspire to
be virtuous this genius move shared by
philosophers like Pacino rich political
leaders like Lorenzo and artists like
Botticelli was to line up our basic
desire on the side of the good so that
we become kinder and sweeter and more
intellectually ambitious not because
we've rejected all the charms of the
world which hardly anyone ever can but
with the help of all the charms of the
world instead of abandoning beauty and
sexiness to vanity and silliness the
leaders of the Renaissance deeply
scholarly and earnest people seize these
and use them to their own ends it's this
move above all that helps to give the
art of the Renaissance its mission drive
and coherence and means the art is still
so charming to us today in our society
the Renaissance has a lot of prestige we
think we're being true to it by going
around its main cities memorizing dates
and ticking off key works but this isn't
really what paying tribute to the
Renaissance should mean it's not about
looking at their world through our eyes
it's about using their eyes to look at
our world we should be trying to
generate a renaissance in our own
societies with the help of these
geniuses learning lessons from them
about how to spend big money perhaps
aren't in finance wisely how to use the
humanities to improve our lives rather
than to impress a scholarly community
how to devote proper energy to creating
livable beautiful cities and how to
harness the power of art so as to make
the good things in the world attractive
and desirable if rather than being just
dutiful tourists we learn to absorb the
ambitions of Renaissance leaders we
might come away from a study of the
Renaissance ready as all the great
Renaissance figures would have wanted us
to be to do the thing that really
matters try to change our world for the
better
you